how about writing in specific character
type language bullies would speak
certain words people pleasers would
speak another absolutely rebel rousers
absolutely and that but that's that's
part of dialogue is it's gonna be
distinctive to whoever the character is
so they're going to you know the guy
that's the the naysayer is always going
to be finding that you know that yeah
we're all doomed this is terrible I
don't know what cartoons that firm but
you know so they're going to find the
negative side to everything and again
that deals with the attitude element
with our baristas again is the there
it's gonna come out their character
comes out through the way they say
things and even what they say
interesting
so so are there certain words though
that we would maybe hear more from one
type versus another like a
people-pleaser maybe they would always
end sentences with a question in their
voice which is another thing which gets
down to the way people speak there are
people who everything is a question to
them and that's kind of gets into the
Yoda thing where Yoda speaks backwards
there are people that everything has a
question mark at the end no matter how
they say it there are people that are
that everything might have like some
sort of an exclamation point it's all
serious damage we've got to do this now
don't you understand my beer is getting
flat I must drink it you know and
everything becomes so serious to them
and those are things that are part of
those characters that are gonna come out
in the way they say things and how they
say things Samuel Jackson's a lot of his
characters yes I don't know if weird
weird choice by character is is a good
idea so you say if a bully might use the
same words or you know a yes man might
use the same words because to me what
makes it interesting is if you take that
core of the character you know they're
the they're the the bully but they say
use different words that makes it unique
because one of the things we always want
to do is make sure we have unique
dialogue if that dialogue has been used
in another movie you can't use it you
know and that gets into saying that you
know the
phrase that I believe you can use that's
been used in other movies is I love you
except you complete me is a much better
line and if you think about all these
love stories they have great lines like
that and then say I love you in
different ways so even when we come to
out the thing about I love you is it's
one of those things when a character
says I love you that you know the we
just go you know I that works it's still
emotionally real even though we've heard
the line a million times before but you
complete me and I used to be able to run
down the list of all these because
there's a great romance movies don't say
I love you they find the different way
to say so almost trying to find the
different way to say something that
hasn't been used before dialog is like
toilet paper you don't want any that's
been used you had me at hello you had me
at hello there's a great one absolutely
and those are the lines we remember you
know we you want the memorable dialogue
and again those would be on bumper
stickers or engraved in gold why i
oughtta let's see that's not even a full
sentence yeah disinherit doesn't have to
be as long as we it brings back the
memory of the you know of the scene of
the TV show of the movie of the whatever
you